[Music]
straight ahead on law and crime daily
new charges in the deadly michigan high
school shooting today i'm announcing
charges against the shooter's parents
jennifer and james crumpley and i don't
want them to have to be maimed or
potentially die
from
an illegal abortion hear women's right
attorney gloria allred's take on the
supreme court abortion case plus i just
held maureen
ask god why
here first hand from accused wife killer
william argy who takes the stand in his
own defense and later alec baldwin's
first interview after the deadly rush
shooting she goes down
i thought to myself
did she faint i would go to any lengths
to undo what happened why the actor
maintains he never pulled the trigger
law on crime daily covering court cases
from coast to coast
welcome everyone to law and crime daily
i'm brian buckmeyer along with terry
austin the parents of the accused
michigan shooter are charged with
involuntary manslaughter prosecutors say
they gave their 15-year-old son access
to the gun and ignored warning signs
that he may stage an attack
on friday oakland county prosecutor
karen mcdonnell announced jennifer and
james crumbly will each face four counts
of involuntary manslaughter stemming
from tuesday's attack that killed four
students and injured eight others their
son fifteen-year-old ethan crumbly is
being charged as an adult in the
shooting he's being held without bail on
charges of terrorism and first-degree
murder officials say teachers reported
crumbly drawing disturbing images the
day before and the day of the shooting
including weapons blood and killing they
say jennifer crumbly sent her son a text
saying quote lol i'm not mad at you you
have to learn not to get caught the day
of the shooting both parents were called
into the school for their son's
concerning behavior
at the meeting james and jennifer
crumbly were shown the drawing and were
advised that they were required to get
their son into counseling within 48
hours
both james and jennifer crumbly failed
to ask their son if he had his gun with
him or where his gun was located and
failed to inspect his backpack for the
presence of the gun which he had with
him
james and jennifer crumbly resisted the
idea of them leaving the school at that
time of their son leaving the school at
that time
instead james and jennifer pumbley left
the high school without their sons
he was returning to the classroom
when the news of the active shooter at
oxford high school had been made public
jennifer crumbly texted to her son at 11
22 i'm sorry at 1 22 p.m
quote ethan
don't do it
at 1 37 pm james crumbly called 911
reporting that a gun was missing from
his house and he believed his son may be
the shooter
us today is criminal defense attorney
taylor coss and terry austin taylor
what's the prosecution's theory for
charging ethan's parents with
involuntary manslaughter especially
considering these text messages and is
it a strong one
so you know uh thanks for having me by
the way this is you know these are
unusual charges in school shootings at a
quarter across america i don't think
we've ever seen charges like this for
the parents but these are unique
circumstances you know we have a
facebook post of the parents taking the
child uh to buy what they call an early
christmas present the gun we have uh
text messages between the parties that
are really disturbing and you know we we
have the sun searching for ammunition in
in class and and when the parents find
out they say lol don't get caught so
this type of behavior uh is what opened
the door to these charges i'm sure
there's more where there came from and i
think in these circumstances it was the
right thing to do yeah definitely more
where these come from where these came
from sorry terry break down this meeting
that ethan had with school
administrators and his parents and how
prosecutors are saying this tragedy
could have been prevented well
absolutely if you know that there's a
problem and you're being told by the
school that there's a problem with your
son you are then notified that there is
a problem here and you need to do
something about it and instead what they
did was to completely ignore those
warnings they knew that the child had a
gun they sent those text messages as you
and taylor have both said and so i
definitely think they should be charged
they are culpable and it will send a
message to the rest of the united states
frankly because that's where we have
these types of shootings occurring but
it'll send a message that you are
responsible for your actions and your
actions are you know when they are
affecting your children you need to do
something yeah it's interesting that
taylor has said and and terry you tagged
on as well these are unique charges we
don't usually see these types of charges
for parents i think these this
prosecution will definitely send a
message throughout the country
on to minnesota where a complete jury is
seated in the trial of ex-cop kim potter
12 people make up the jury with two
alternates in total there are seven men
and seven women ten are white two are
asian and one is black the ethnicity of
the last alternate juror has not yet
been released potter is facing
manslaughter charges in the shooting
death of dante wright in april of this
year body cameras caught the entire
incident on video police were pulling
right over for an expired registration
tag and determined he had an outstanding
warrant when they attempted to take him
into custody police say he resisted
potter warns right that she is going to
tase him but pulls her gun instead and
shoots right once in the chest potter's
defense maintains the shooting was an
accident the trial is set to begin on
wednesday december 8th on the next
episode of law and crime daily we'll
delve into the charges against potter
ahead of opening statements
i've
determined then that an appropriate time
to be looking for trial
will be in january of 2023
so that will still provide
14 months
of preparation time from now going
forward
a trial date is officially set for the
so-called doomsday duo accused of murder
accused murderers chad and lori valo day
bell the pair face charges in connection
to the death of chad dabel's wife tammy
who died suddenly in 2019. deva refused
an autopsy just weeks later he and
laurie valodebel were married both are
also charged with the murder of her two
children tyler ryan and j.j valo the
bodies of both children were found on
chad dabel's property in june 2020. the
couple was given the nickname doomsday
duel for their strong end of times
belief and the string of sudden deaths
that surrounded them on thursday a judge
adjourned for 2023 trial date for the
co-defendants as lori valodebel's
competency to stand trial remains up in
the air
no timeline as to when she may be
restored to competency those are issues
that we can talk about
privately
and as far as the trial being set either
a year or two years from now
it
does take some time or mitigation
the process with mitigation specialists
and investigators
that process has not started yet because
uh of her
incompetency
and
and
whether or not she'll waive her right to
speedy trial is still an issue
that she cannot decide at this point
um
and so i think the general timelines
yeah it does take two to three years to
get a a death penalty case to trial if
that's what the state is seeking
the trial expected to last about 10
weeks including jury selection the
prosecution says they will seek the
death penalty if daebel is convicted
still ahead on law and crime daily and
accused murderer takes the stand in his
own defense in the trial of william argy
versus new hampshire here what has he
said happened in the moments leading up
to her death but first could roe v wade
be overturned by the supreme court law
in crime's own terry austin hears from
women's rights attorney gloria allred
for her take on the controversial topic
[Music]
hi this is dan abrams with exciting news
for all of our law and crime followers
on youtube you can now get the live law
and crime network with youtube tv for
all of your daily live trial coverage
legal news expert analysis and original
true crime programs subscribe to youtube
tv today and then locate law and crime
in the channel guide and for only 1.99 a
month you can add the network to your
bundle watch lawn crime every day with
youtube tv we put you in the jury box
[Music]
welcome back supreme court justice is
now in deliberation to potentially
overturn the famed roe v wade decision
our own terry austin heard from a
high-profile activist who explains what
the fallout could be from such a
monumental change
brian i spoke with women's rights leader
gloria allred who says overturning roe v
wade could lead to dozens more of the
state's tightening the restrictions on
abortion laws on wednesday justices
heard arguments focused on a mississippi
law that bans abortions more than 15
weeks after conception supreme court
justices previously ruled states cannot
ban abortions before viability or when a
fetus can survive outside of the womb
viability is now considered between 22
and 24 weeks mississippi officials say
scientific advances allow babies to
survive earlier gloria allred tells me
should roe v wade be overturned many
other states would be triggered to
overturn abortion laws as well she told
me her own personal story her strong
convictions on abortion legalization
stemmed from those stories
this is before roe v wade uh and i was a
single parent
uh not earning much money uh and i was
raped at gunpoint in mexico i became
pregnant came back
uh to california it was a crime
for a doctor to provide a
an abortion uh in california at that
time they caught it to assist in a
miscarriage is what they called it
and uh and so i had to find a back alley
abortionist not a licensed medical
a provider like a doctor or a nurse
somebody who would just do it for the
money he did it
uh i ended up uh hemorrhaging in a
bathtub
uh being taken by ambulance to a
hospital at 106 degree fever had to be
packed in ice
uh and uh almost did not survive
from the infection this is why i'm so
committed to roe v wade uh that abortion
has to be safe it has to be legal
bring back criminal defense attorney
taylor cost and terry austin terry what
else did gloria arwin said about
scotus's deciding of this case one of
the things she said to me brian is we
have to keep up the fight we cannot lose
this right it is a personal right it is
a right that we've had for decades as
she said it's something that if the
legislation doesn't do something in the
congress then we have to get out we have
to protest we have to fight this battle
on all fronts and believe me she was
very serious about it you heard her
personal story and so it left me
thinking that this is one of those
rights that we cannot afford to lose
now the supreme court could do a number
of things but let's focus on two of
those the court could limit its decision
to just the mississippi law or overturn
roe v wade altogether what do you think
it could do in this case
so i think uh you know the the
mississippi law in between is dead i
think it's finished i think that they
have the you know that's in their sights
and it's done and now it's really a
matter of if those last one or two uh
conservative appointed judges on the
supreme court are willing to go to the
distance you know clarence thomas has
been waiting for an opportunity like
this some of the others have as well and
so the question really is are they going
to keep it to just you know the local
law which i think is already a done
decision or are they going to expand it
and i think you know this is an
important fight it leaves our country in
a very difficult position and you know
hillary clinton actually had a very
interesting tweet the other day which
said we cannot leave our grandchildren
with less rights and privileges than we
ourselves had and that's the situation
we're putting them in right now it's an
interesting quote nonetheless and
especially since this uh landmark case
has been around since the 73 going
forward uh the question is what rights
will men and women especially women of
this country have with the autonomy of
their body going forward
up the co thank you both up the coast in
new york friday marks the week the end
of the week in the federal trial of
elaine maxwell
maxwell faces a slew of charges for sex
trafficking for allegedly helping
epstein groom young teenage girls for
sexual abuse maxwell's plead not guilty
to all charges as her defense argues
she's a scapegoat for jeffrey epstein
her longtime companion in court on
friday the defense started the day with
cross-examination of juan alessi the man
who ran epstein's palm beach home for
more than a decade much of friday
afternoon's testimony was visual
including content not available to the
press or public prosecutors later called
crime scene investigator gregory
parkinson to walk through videos and
photos of epstein's home the exhibits
including a photo prosecutor described
as sexualized image of a young girl
displayed outside epstein's bedroom
epstein was found dead by suicide two
years ago
two months after his arrest on federal
sex trafficking charges
coming up will william rg comes to his
own defense against charges that he
murdered his wife as her children slept
here is testimony from the new hampshire
courtroom next plus alec baldwin speaks
out for the first time since a young
mother was fatally shot on a movie set
more more from his exclusive sit-down
interview with abc news ahead on long
crime daily
[Music]
welcome back to long crime daily the
defense rests his case after accused
murderer and defendant william bill argy
takes the stand archie faced his life in
prison for the murder of his wife
maureen prosecutors say he strangled or
suffocated her after saying she wanted a
divorce they say he attempted suicide
after killing her ran off and gambled at
a casino argy was also the sole
beneficiary of his wife's 400 thousand
dollar life insurance policy at the time
the defendant faced a gambling addiction
job loss and growing debt the defense
argued she killed herself and that argy
found her in bed with a sheet around her
neck on friday argy testified recounting
the morning he says he found his wife
dead in their bedroom
i saw
my wife with
a bed sheet around her neck
and uh
jim between her
nightstand and her
in the bed
on cross-examination the prosecution
pushed rg to reveal what he did with his
wife's cell phone after she died
when driving i got frustrated
that
i would not continue to have the phone
and
i threw it out on 395. phone went dead
and you threw it up right tossed it away
abandoned it
right correct just let you abandon your
dead
wife right
i did not abandon my cousins
here with us is criminal defense
attorney taylor coss and co-host terry
austin terry with so much circumstantial
evidence against him how was rg's direct
examination i thought it was terrible
really i mean he said the right words
there's no question about it it was
clear that he had been well prepared by
his attorney but it seemed so fake it
seemed so staged he had an excuse for
everything and the excuses really didn't
make sense he for instance put the bed
sheet in the bag when he left after
killing her so why did he bring the bed
sheet it just doesn't make sense to me i
mean taylor usually when the defendant
takes the stand the direct examination
is the easy part so let's ask him about
the hard part is there anything rg could
have said that would have led to a not
guilty and how do you think he held up
on cross-examination
i mean you know sometimes people are
just not meant for this and you look at
the way he testified in his mannerisms
and the way he's communicating and it's
a terrible thing to say but he just
looked guilty and he acted guilty his
answers were not strong they were not
focused not to mention the evidence is
fairly strong against him so you know he
was in a bad position and he did not
help himself yeah i mean hindsight is 20
20 and we'll obviously find out when the
verdict comes in but the question here i
think that people are going to be asking
himself until that verdict comes in is
should william rg have taken the stand
or maybe he should have just remained
silent of course that's his decision
that's his right nothing that any lawyer
can tell him otherwise but of course
we'll see when that verdict comes in
when we come back alec baldwin's first
interview since the fatal shooting on
the set of his latest movie why the
actor says he never pulled the trigger
and calls the victim a friend all that
still ahead
[Music]
welcome back to law and crime daily
we're hearing from alec baldwin for the
first time since the deadly shooting on
the set of his latest movie in an
exclusive interview with abc the actress
says he never pulled the trigger
well the trigger wasn't pulled i didn't
pull the trigger so you never pulled the
trigger no no no no i would never point
a gun at anyone and pull a trigger at
them never
on october 21st 42 year old helena
hutchins was killed and director joel
souza was injured when baldwin fired a
weapon with a live round on the new
mexico movie set of rust baldwin says he
believed the gun did not have any live
rounds in it and that he never pulled
the trigger since the shooting multiple
losses have been filed against baldwin
and other producers as several crew
members claim emotional distress and
deliberate infliction of harm in its
first interview since the deadly
shooting the 63 year old actor sat down
with abc
jory stephanopoulos he calls helena
hutchins a friend
that her work was beautiful she was
someone who was loved by everyone who
worked with and liked by everyone who
worked and admired
[Music]
i'm sorry
[Music]
but admired by everybody who um
who worked with
her
taylor as a criminal defense attorney
alec baldwin a man who could potentially
face criminal and civil charges did his
explanation in this interview with abc
help him at all
you know i think it probably did um you
know the court of public opinion is huge
in these matters uh it's it's tough to
get individual liability on things like
this and so you know the narrative that
was building up uh especially with all
these lawsuits coming from other uh
members of the crew and stuff was that
essentially that baldwin took a gun
pointed at someone pulled the trigger
and you know callously murdered them you
know didn't mean to have a live round in
there but so to get out there that that
narrative is not accurate and to put his
own touch on it to show the emotion and
feeling behind it i think it probably
did help him yeah absolutely i mean yes
people are going to say he's an actor he
can turn on the waterworks and turn it
off but i think it is going to help him
to some degree talking about some of the
people in the background and some of the
stage individuals terry mr looper a
cameraman had many as it appears safety
complaints and even walked off the set
with a number of other camera people but
the argument is he's just the cameraman
and didn't deal with any of these safety
issues on set so how's looper's opinion
going to affect any potential charges oh
his opinion is definitely going to
affect the civil lawsuits no question
about it we know already that there are
at least two civil lawsuits one of them
was actually brought by the chief
lighting individual he too has nothing
to do with safety but he brought a suit
claiming that there was negligence on
that set and the other second suit that
we know about also is claiming
negligence so it really doesn't matter
you don't have to be a safety expert to
understand and realize and recognize the
fact that there is something wrong on
the set and they need to do more yeah
don't forget that it's not just the
potential of murder charges there is uh
manslaughter charges there's criminal
negligent uh homicide there's reckless
homicide so when it comes down to the
level of intent or men's rey as lawyers
will call it it's still up in the air as
to what alec baldwin could be facing and
as taylor and terry has said so many
statements could lend to that well thank
you for joining us here on law and crime
daily we'll see you next time as we
discuss justice in america
[Music]
you